I don't want to jinx anything but Eddie
Redmayne was here last New Year's Eve as
he left the building I said good luck
with the Oscars only won an Oscar
reducing him I realized we have been
like talking and catching up and then
you were like an Academy Award winner I
was like holy God it's really rare
congratulations
never talked to you after that I know
and here's it's weird you don't talk
about these things but you'd have had
one was it was it the night you won your
Oscar the night I won my I don't want to
talk about that night I had a whole
meltdown um okay I was reading it was
like birth control confusion so I was
like hormonal I fell on my face I forgot
to thank the director so I was just like
what does it all mean
nothing I just like I came home crying
that my friend was like ordered the
wrong pizza I was in thin crust it was
thick crust I was like I've had a very
different scenes of the Redmayne
household
slightly different oh really well
basically I have a plethora of brothers
and they're sort of favorite thing is to
sort of come well I did this film couple
years ago called savage grace with
Julianne Moore
keep going quickly sorceress you left
them a car
couple years ago book called savage
grace and it was one of my early one of
the first jobs that I'm so proud of it
was with Julianne Moore involved incest
I played her son and she sleeps with him
to to sort of try and change her
sexuality anywhere I was so pleased have
got a job I'm so proud of it and they
came to the London Film Festival
premiere and it was only sort of as I
was sitting down surrounded by my family
with all my brothers sitting next to my
dad basically looking at him like this
as I was about to have to do a love
scene with my mother in the film just to
see what his reaction would be that's
always their thing they just sort of sit
next they see who can get closest to dad
in order to watch what his yeah it's
gonna be I had to kick my brother out
from like a word season for a little bit
cuz he tried to arm-wrestle Matthew
McConaughey like not into it
his Winter's Bone nobody knew who I was
he's mother he took down the call that
my mom is your how was your mom during
premieres she's pretty good actually
she's normal but only because I always
say to her I remember we had this
amazing experience at the Tony Awards
when she came as my date and I was like
mum what happens at these things I think
is they come up on cameras and they look
at your face or when I don't win you've
got to look you know you can't get yeah
no really I love my mama she is quite
competitive
anyway this moment happened and and I
was nominated for a prize and then I was
lucky enough to win and I was so elated
but my mum I'd given such a grilling to
that just she just so sorry
mr. darling your supermodel you rock
star Eddie you movie star I'll marry of
the steno I wanted to go madness madness
madness and he stops the middle game
it's like what and I realized I had lost
my mind and I said I just said never
mind